our first presenter is the reason why I
bought 12 cellphones she is last year's
Best Supporting Actress ladies and
gentlemen with Miss Catherine zeta-jones
for an actor the moment the envelope is
opened is one of the most extraordinary
experiences one can imagine and in a few
seconds one of these exceptionally
gifted actors will understand exactly
what that means the nominees for Best
Performance by an actor in a supporting
role are
alec baldwin in the cooler Benicio del
Toro in 21 grams German ensue in in
America
Tim Robbins in Mystic River Ken Watanabe
in The Last Samurai
and have no nails the Oscar goes to Tim
Robbins
this is the first acting nomination and
first Academy Award for Tim Robbins he
was nominated once before for directing
dead man walking
oh boy wow thank you so much members of
the Academy this is really a lovely
lovely honor I'd like to thank my fellow
nominees or all spectacular and I all I
want to work with all of you in a movie
at some point Dennis Lehane brian
helgeland for the writing of this
amazing script Clint Eastwood you're
you're so great you're such an amazing
director and you're making my mantle
very crowded thank you it's due to you
sir
my fellow cast members Sean Penn Kevin
Bacon Marcia Gay Harden Laura Linney
Laurence Fishburne the crew was
fantastic
Tony Howard Lisa casteller Alan horn
Bruce Berman Jeff robinov from Warner
Brothers Joe Himes Judy Hoyt Rob Lorenz
my mom and dad Dave del Gaby Terry hang
in there you can kick it
geese family your dad's smiling down on
you Susan I love you so much
ever Jack miles thanks for being there
for me
Susan thanks for being the best friend
one could have the actors gang in
embedded in New York thank you so much
for putting up with me being here and I
I would love I would like to say one
more thing if I in this movie I play a
victim of abuse and violence and if you
are out there and are a person that has
had that tragedy befall you there is no
shame and no weakness in seeking help
and counselling it is sometimes the
strongest thing that you can do to stop
the cycle of violence
thank you